my name is Josiah lippincott I'm from  tulare California from a politics major  at hillsdale college this spring I'm  interning with the heritage foundation  in Washington DC is part of the  Washington Hillsdale internship program  we call whip for short we bring anywhere  between 10 to 20 students a semester out  to DC they take two or three classes and  they in turn on the hill at the Heritage  Foundation really anywhere they want to  we find somebody coming out of college  who has some practical real-world  experience especially experience that  applies to what we do it really sets  them apart Washington is one of those  places that kids can learn a lot and  gain a lot just from being here for a  few months and that sense coming here  and having that internship experience i  can guarantee will be life-changing  you